[Music]
good evening and welcome to Washington
I'm John Roberts the rollercoaster of
story of Jessie smaller took an
unexpected turn today as charges against
Smollett were suddenly dropped the black
and gay actor was accused by police and
the prosecutor of staging a racial and
homophobic attack because he was unhappy
with his compensation on the television
show Empire small its attorneys say the
16 felony counts have been dismissed the
case sealed in his $10,000 bond
forfeited to the city but denied that a
deal was made the prosecutor still says
he believes Smollett lied about the
attack despite dropping the charges
Smollett said he has been truthful
inconsistent since day one Chicago Mayor
Rahm Emanuel called the decision a
whitewash of justice correspondent Matt
Finn is in Chicago to try to connect all
the dots for us the night along that
johnjessy Smollett was scheduled to
appear in court again on April 7th for
those 16 felony counts of lying to
police but then today in a shocking
twist the case against jussie Smollett
was suddenly dropped do I think justice
was served no Chicago's Police
Superintendent and Mayor Rahm Emanuel
are slamming the Cook County State's
Attorney's office for suddenly dropping
16 felony counts of lying to police
against actor Jessie Smollett promotion
this is a whitewash of justice this mr.
Smolin who committed this this this
whole period if he wanted to clear his
name the way to do that was in a court
of law in an emergency hearing today a
judge granted prosecutors request to
drop charges against Smollett in a
statement the Cook County State's
Attorney's Office wrote after reviewing
all of the facts and circumstances of
the case including mr. small adds a
volunteer service in the community and
agreement to forfeit his bond to the
city of Chicago we believe this outcome
is a just disposition and appropriate
resolution to this case small at
speaking out after the ruling I've been
truthful and consistent on every single
level since day one
I would not be my mother son if I was
capable of one drop of what I was
accused of superintendent Eddie Johnson
says police carried out a meticulous
investigation with dozens of detectives
and concluded that small let cut the
ocean taro brothers a $3,500 check to
pretend to beat him call him racial and
homophobic slurs and say this is mega
country small let's attorney says
Chicago's top cop is wrong and accused
the police of trying the case in public
I have no idea where that came from
which is why you should allow
investigation and allow the state to to
investigate a charge before you go to
the press executive producers for the
hit show Empire caught jussie Smollett
scare achter from the final two episodes
of this season now 20 Century Fox is
standing by him riding in a statement
jussie Smollett has always maintained
his innocence and we are gratified that
all charges against him have been
dismissed the Cook County State's
Attorney's Office in a statement now
says that it did not exonerate Jesse
small light today and that it stands by
Chicago police the charges were dropped
against Jesse Smollett in exchange for
community service and that he forfeit
that ten thousand dollar bond
John quite a remarkable turn of events
Matt fed in Chicago tonight Matt thanks